you get the best view of the city of
Coimbra from the water
every morning athletes head out to the
Rio Mondego rowing has a long tradition
here in the city
when you are in the river you can look
around you almost see the whole city and
have one of the most beautiful
University from Europe and then it's
very important to us to see the
university every day Mon well Peter ends
his workout just before 11 a.m.
he has a lecture to attend all rose in
Queen bruh lead to the historic city
centre past the old survey Locati draw
the santa cruz church
and the Jean M de manga high above the
old town is the University of Coimbra
the city's main landmark the university
was founded in 1290 by our King
Dionysius also known as Don Denis yonder
over several centuries the university
was moved back and forth from Lisbon to
Coimbra and from Coimbra back to Lisbon
in 1537 it was then finally located
permanently in Coimbra Queen Margot saw
some of the old traditions from back
then live on today
for instance many students still wear
long black capes called Coppa
the university is famous for its golden
library the bibliothèque aswan inna
which houses more than 60,000 ancient
volumes this is I know the library was
built at a time when our King wanted to
demonstrate his glory and power sign a
pot on Zion amat Feigenbaum and there's
something special in this library
there's a colony of bats leader moyson
they protect the books because they eat
the book lice that devour the binding
paste in the book resin the most
magnificent view of the city which in
the 12th and 13th century was the
capital of Portugal is the Baroque bell
tower the capilla de sal mcgann in the
late afternoon
beneath the bell tower the photo group
part Alito's command a go gathers to
play their songs about student life
for us it's a narrative of course that
we have to respect but it's also a place
where we can be creative and do new
things that are not yet done it's a way
of showing the University and the city
so and it's of course a part of us that
it's a good part of our lives is turned
around these kinds of these kind of
music yes the members of part alito's da
Mondego met during their time at the
university and they still enjoy coming
back here
students in Quinn para live in places
like this called Republic us their
ancient buildings in the old town that
have housed students for centuries what
I like most about living here are the
traces of history throughout the house
they give me contact with the people who
lived here before today they might be
doctors or musicians but they lived here
back in the 1940s or 50s and experienced
or felt what I feel today it's a great
responsibility to preserve the past and
to defend the ideas and values behind it
among those values are the communal
dinners as well as the obligatory glass
of port after dinner that's enjoyed
right around the corner in the
traditional Portuguese bar
lemur is the best quest study in
Portugal there's this amazing
environment around the student Cumbre is
one of Portugal's less famous cities but
it's well worth exploring a place whose
ancient walls Balai a youthful
atmosphere